[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing defense against the dark arts
defense against the dark art is a core
subject taught at hogwarts
that purportedly teaches students how to
defend themselves
against dark magic more specifically
we're going to be taking a look
at the defense against the dark arts
teaching role at hogwarts
and deep diving into each and every
professor
ranking them from worst to best however
i will mention this i'm only going to be
including the main
data professors during the storyline of
the books
there were many professors before the
earliest professor on this list
and there will be many after the latest
professor on this list
now if you're a proper harry potter fan
then you'll know that the defense
against the dark arts position
is cursed this is because years ago
tom riddle voldemort himself was denied
the role
and decided to curse the position the
resulting curse meant that
for as long as the role existed no
professor would be able to hold the
position
for more than one school year and tom
was true to his word
after cursing the role each and every
professor had their own unique reason
for vacating the role with such an
abundance of different professors in one
role
there has certainly been some variety
and today i want to take a look at each
of these unique individuals
which ones were the worst the best which
ones actually
taught the children something without
further ado i present to you
every defense against the dark arts
teacher ranked from worst
to best worst amicus caro
the worst spot on this list goes to
amicus caro
when the ministry fell in 1997 and the
wizarding world started falling to
pieces
he was assigned as the new defense
against the dark arts professor
you probably didn't expect to see him
here particularly as there were some
bad professors and presumably amicus ran
a pretty tight ship
however while amicus taught a reasonably
productive defense against the dark arts
class
primarily due to the threat of his
hostile nature he didn't actually teach
any kind of defense he just taught dark
arts
the class just became something else
altogether under his tenure
and even though he now taught dark arts
which was one of his specialties
he didn't even do that particularly well
vincent krabb
who ends up killing himself with fiend
fire learned the spell from amicus
and it's certainly his fault that crab
ended up dying
improperly teaching dark magic to an
impressionable young man
amicus was a particularly cruel teacher
and was known to implement
torturous punishments in order to
discipline students
neville told the trio that umbridge's
punishments were tame compared to caro
so i can only imagine what being a
student under him would have been like
dolores umbridge oh boy where do i start
dolores umbridge became a defense
against the dark arts professor at a
time
when the ministry began interfering with
hogwarts affairs
fudge who vehemently denied that
voldemort had returned
in spite of nearly undeniable evidence
began acting
rationally out of well fear and made it
his job to make dumbledore's life
difficult
who implored cornelius to see reason at
this stage
doris umbridge was planted into hogwarts
and with backing from the ministry
she quickly stirred things up eventually
moving on to become hogwarts high
inquisitor
and even headmistress however she
started as a professor
and right away it became clear that
umbridge had no intention of teaching
any sort
of standardized curriculum she had her
own plans in mind
with the imminent threat of lord
voldemort's return one would have
expected that the very course taught to
oppose dark magic
would have provided more substance
however dolores instead taught a useless
class full of
theory and absolutely no practical
application
those who opposed her were subject to
cruel and unusual punishment
hush and she obnoxiously exercised
whatever power she had
in every instance that she could
umbridge teaching that year was
basically just a waste of the students
time
and she genuinely taught nothing of
value stifling any of the students
attempts
to actually try and learn to protect
themselves
queerness quirrell amazingly despite
having voldemort on the back of his head
quirrell still made it above umbridge
and the carouse here's the thing
quirrell didn't stifle students ability
to learn or teach them dark magic
but he was basically just a useless
nervous wreck
in his time as professor he basically
taught nothing of value
and i mean why would he voldemort was
controlling him the entire
time furthermore jk rowling once stated
that quirrell's special ability was that
he was learned in the theory of
defensive magic
but less adept in the practice what this
tells me is that krill wasn't
incompetent or unwise he was just not a
good practitioner of the magic that he
taught
in the year 1990 coral took a year-long
sabbatical
he told his peers that the sabbatical
was an opportunity for him
to gain first-hand experience in the
field where in reality
his objective was to find lord voldemort
exceedingly curious about what had
happened to the dark lord
who tyrannized the wizarding world for
years on end voldemort recounts his
first meeting with quirrell
a wizard young foolish and gullible
wandered across my path in the forest i
had made my home
oh he seemed the very chance i'd been
dreaming of for he was a teacher at
dumbledore's school
he was easy to bend my will he brought
me back to this country
and after a while i took possession of
his body to supervise him closely as he
carried out my orders
i don't think that i could place a
wizard controlled by voldemort much
higher on the list
but he was definitely still better than
umbridge and the cairos
gilderoy lockhart next up we have the
recipient of witch weekly's most
charming smile award
and you know what i'll let him introduce
himself
me gilderoy lockhart order of merlin
third class
honorary member of the dark force
defense league and five-time winner of
which
weekly's most charming smile award but i
don't talk about that
i didn't get rid of the band and banshee
by smiling at her
lockhart was an interesting choice for
the role of defense against the dark
arts professor
you see to much of the wizarding world
lockhart was impressive he had written
books about his achievements
conquering all manners of dark creatures
and on paper he was the perfect person
for the role
however what many didn't know was that
he was a big phony
lockhart was ostentatious egotistical
and quite frankly
delusional lockhart capitalized on
achievements of genuinely powerful
witches and wizards
by quite deviously implementing memory
charms that made them forget altogether
what they had done
with no one to lay claim into these
accomplishments and
no one to refute that it wasn't lockhart
who had achieved them
he claimed them for himself of course
dumbledore knew all along that lockhart
was indeed a fraud
as personally he knew some of the
witch's wizards
that lockhart had performed memory
charms on however
with no one to fill the role that year
dumbledore thought what the heck
and gave the position to lockhart
despite being entirely incompetent
lockhart is reasonably high up in the
list because
in dumbledore's own words there is
plenty to be learned
even from a bad teacher what not to do
how
not to be alistair madai moody but
really
barty crouch jr 1994 was the year that
once again a new event against the dark
arts teacher took over
famed death eater captor alastair maddai
moody
despite his outwardly striking and
intimidating appearance
moody was one of the good guys he was in
the business of capturing dark wizards
and business was booming the prospect of
having alastair moody teaching
defense against the dark arts was
exciting i mean he was an expert after
all but at the same time
there was something odd about moody that
something was that it wasn't moody at
all
it was barty crouch jr strangely despite
the fact that he was a death eater
impersonating a hogwarts professor he
still did a much better job
than some of the aforementioned names on
the list he was quite bold
and rather uninhibitedly exercised
unforgivable forbidden curses in the
classroom
like imperio crucio and devadikadavra
but his vast knowledge on the curses
actually proved to be quite informative
he didn't directly teach students to
perform them like the caros
he just taught them what they were and
how they worked but this certainly
helped out the trio
moving forward here's the thing about
barty crouch jr
he was a really talented wizard and
though he unfortunately turned over to
the dark side
he still had an affinity for learning
and was an exceptional student during
his time
at hogwarts it only makes sense that
even while serving the death eaters
he wanted to impart some of his vast
knowledge onto the students
i like to imagine that even if maddai
had taught the class himself
that the curriculum would have been
quite similar severus
snape in theory severus snape was the
perfect defense against the dark arts
teacher
he had a profound understanding of both
sides of the magical spectrum
and knew more about the dark arts than
most making him the perfect
candidate to teach students defense
however
at this stage snape was still playing
double agent and this
is something that we need to consider he
had a lot going on
deceiving one of the darkest and most
powerful wizards of all time
and this meant that he was pretty
distracted he also had the old
kill dumbledore to save malfoy's soul
thing going on
he still taught well and the student
certainly got a considerable amount of
knowledge from the class
but that doesn't mean he was the best
defense against the dark arts teacher
could he have been probably but was he
no
so with that said who was remus
lupin in my eyes remus lupin was
unquestionably
the best defense against the dark arts
professor he had a vast
knowledge of the dark arts and how to
defend against them but he was also an
excellent teacher
he knew how to impart his knowledge onto
others in a productive way
balancing both theory and practical
application
to ensure that when the time came his
students would be able to implement the
magic that he taught
teachers are people that we're supposed
to look up to not necessarily just from
an academic standpoint
but from a moral standpoint as well
remus lupin was an excellent role model
to his students
a brave patient and kind man that knew
how to balance education
with an element of well fun most notably
remus was responsible for teaching harry
the patronus charm
and this was unquestionably one of the
most important things
that harry ever learned from anyone it
came in handy and reasonably often
and without remus i'm not sure harry
would have gotten the hang of it
so quickly if remus had been able to
keep his role as defense against the
dark arts professor
for more than one year i think the
battle of hogwarts would have gone
very differently and that's it for this
video do you guys agree with my list
give me your worst the best dada
professor rankings
until next time remember it is the
quality of one's convictions
the determined success not the number of
[Music]
followers
you